okay high interest on the phones today
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's go let's go
to our favorite Israeli collarbones in
New Jersey Boas what's new with you hey
David
just wanted to call it Israeli okay but
your name is a very popular name in
Israel
really oh okay you didn't know that um
no no I thought it was I thought it was
a popular in India I didn't know Israeli
okay very good
yeah and I've only met I've only met one
person in the United States with the
same name as me but that wasn't in San
Francisco okay so I'm calling today I
just want to get your opinion on
libertarian auditors there seems to be a
pretty large community on YouTube and
I'm wondering if you have no not at all
can you tell me about it yeah so
essentially these are you know
libertarian under less and they
essentially check the government you
know so they go out to public buildings
and they and you know they practice
their rights to record and to do this or
that and they usually do this as a
practice to catch you know uneducated
you know officers or law enforcement who
don't quite know the law and it's kind
of an educational tool yeah yeah
so is this similar to the brown poll
that deliberately go to like the Border
Patrol checkpoints and assert that they
don't have to provide any ID or they go
to you know sobriety checkpoint like
there's people that seek out
conversations and confrontations with
law enforcement to film it and then put
it on YouTube yes got it listen my vow
is I file get I'll answer your question
more specifically but I find it pretty
entertaining to watch those but I also
find it to be kind of a sad waste of
time for the people doing it right well
um I guess there is an argument there
that it is
it could be a waste of time but there
was actually a story yesterday there is
a youtuber audited a blind man his two
channels blind justice he actually uses
cameras as an assistive device you know
because he goes back home and you know
places where he goes
usually by himself he has his wife
review them and she gives him
information on the places he's been but
he also uses it to try to you know
practice his rights to use a camera and
to go to public places right um well it
turns out that he went and uh Guilford
knew North Carolina he went into a
public health office and he was actually
like assaulted and battered and taken to
the hospital by a security guard
so we refused to identify himself and it
was kind of crazy I was just that's just
uh it was uploaded automatically to
livestream so it was really crazy
um I guess the counter-argument could be
that I think it's important to to show
people like I know specifics of their
rights yeah listen boas here's my
thought on this I can see it both ways
like on the one hand if people have a
right to film and they're being told
they can't film that's wrong and we
should make sure that people know know
the policy and all of that stuff and and
I totally respect that and with that at
the same time being known for like hey I
went to a public health building and
they didn't let me film but I uploaded
it so now everybody knows that you can
film there I feel like there are bigger
fish to fry there's lower hanging fruit
I don't know it's hard for me to get too
fired up about like that's the issue if
you go in North Carolina to the public
health building you damned wet well be
able to better be able to film like I
get it but at the same time it's not how
I would spend my activism
capital so to speak right now of course
and last point or yeah last point good
all right give me sex
I think I think that I think it's an
it's actually kind of an important
connection to make you know because I
feel like a lot of these libertarian
auditors are come from the right side of
you know politics you know are generally
conservative yeah but they can share a
lot of the same opinions about police
officers and law enforcement and you
know local city officials you know that
maybe certain communities like black
communities like as a black man like in
New Jersey you know I see the kind of
distaste as a black man in a white
suburb that police officers have towards
me you know if I were to go around Lois
you're a black man yes I've never heard
of anyone named Boas who was black
that's interesting and you're saying
your family's Indian no no I'm a mix I
come from a mixed family a mixed adopted
family middle names
Ebru alone German West African Native
American whole lots of stuff okay
well listen here's that yeah so I think
what you're pointing out is this this
these social libertarians often are on
the left and the right there's a lot of
overlap in social civil libertarianism
from left to right it's on economic
libertarianism excuse me we're left and
right tend to UM to sort of split off
but yes you're absolutely right that
there can be an alliance there boas I
appreciate the call I hope to hear from
you again I'm going to move on because I
have a lot of people holding